i dhruv
how are you now i hope uh you're doing
fine now
okay so i've shared the live stream link
with you all so if any one of you
misses out on the meeting you can join
there
so while you're waiting for others to
join let me just take you quickly and
tell you how you need to sign up
yourself
and create an account and get the access
to the material on the portal
it's really good to see so many new
names today it's really good that
you all
okay sorry for the echo i'm sharing my
screen
and so who all of you have already
signed up on learn
let me know by uh text on on the chat
maybe
by sending out one or yes and those who
are not signed up
i would request them to please sign up
on learn
i'm sharing the link with you all in the
chat
here is the link while others are
joining it would be great if you sign up
so that you can go along with us in the
session itself
and those who are already
signed up i request them to please
update their profiles
so all you have to do is please go
to your profile by clicking on your name
and i would want you to add a profile
picture
and also link in your social accounts so
that first of all your name it should be
the full name that you would want on
your certificate
because this is the name that would be
reflecting on the certificates as well
and why i'm asking to link your social
it's just because
we keep on featuring our best profiles
so we would want to have your social
links with us as well
and i would also explain more advantages
of having an updated profile in the
meantime
i think many of them have joined let's
wait for two more minutes
hi casual hi
ali can i know in which country are you
placed so that i am aware of your time
zone
hi ekiba
okay so i think let's get started we
have our participants and
others can join in the meantime so i
welcome you all to today's research
fellowship
meeting so before i uh start
with the meeting let me first of all
introduce you to the research fellowship
program
as we have a lot many new participants
here as well
so this bioinformatics research
fellowship program is a structured
program that guides students through
various areas of big data bioinformatics
research
using practical examples and during this
program
we would go through several high quality
research publications
and would learn about applications of
computational biology
in projects through these publications
this kind of experience would allow
beginners to try computational biology
techniques on public domain data
making it possible to work with large
files and extract meaningful
information from patient samples animal
models
cell lines and microbiota as well
a prop the program would provide support
and mentorship
and therefore it is an intensive
research program that would be involving
training tasks
access to our online sessions and a
guide on the implementation of
learned skills to proposed research
ideas as well
so let me quickly introduce ourselves
before we
begin with the session
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple
academic and commercial collaborators to
develop
easy-to-use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible omixlogic is an
international program that is running in
five different regions with over 10 000
users around the world
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with
with local and regional coordinators
that are helping refine local program
logistics
and leverage our online training
resources adapting them to the needs of
students and researchers around the
world
my name is sunalika ray and i'm the
omixlogic community manager i'm
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users that are a part of a
bioinformatics community
managed by pine biotech and i'm honored
to have been working with a team that
that collectively has an amazing
experience in the area
including the other co-founders of the
company dr alfred trauber
who comes from a medical background with
expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation
and one of his major projects is the
establishment of the
probable bioinformatics research center
which has been at the core of what we do
then we have dr leonard brotzky he's the
director of proper bioinformatics
research
center and is an expert in
bioinformatics and
biostatistics he has numerous
publications on bioinformatics and over
the course of his career he has
developed multiple novel algorithmic
approaches
to biomedical data analysis these have
been widely used in basic and
translational research
in biotechnology pharmaceutical r d
agriculture and basic research as well
our platform is a result of hard work by
some of the
people who are mentioned here on the
right julia panov is an expert by
informatician and has helped prepare
many of the materials that we would use
avitovsky is a computer scientist and
needs the development of t
bio info platform that we would use dr
harpreet has an expertise in the
application of statistical machine
learning techniques and biomedical data
and development of prediction tools and
databases as well
and she looks after the curriculum
development by informatics and data
science course development for the
company
then we have dr mohit mazumdar with us
who is an expert by information with
multiple publications in peer-reviewed
journals
and collaborations in industry and
academia
and over the past several years dr mohit
mazumdar has been developing
collaborations with universities as a
mentor and project lead
for omixlogic training and research
fellowship
so let's start by signing up to
learn.comics logic
this is an educational portal that would
help you get started on your
bioinformatics research journey
so those who joined us just a while ago
i uh was telling that we need to sign up
on the omixlogic portal i would share
the link again and those who have signed
up
it's good to have them here you can now
update your profile
as i have told you so i would be
waiting for you you all can sign up now
i've shared the link
uh let me show you how you can sign
up
so here is the sign up page you need to
enter your mail id you would get a link
and then you have to create your
password as well and then sign in
you can also sign up by your social
accounts
and it would be an easy way to sign up
on the portal
and then you would be good to go for
your courses and
other opportunities as well
so let's uh wait for the participants
who have joined to sign up
let me know once you are done i would be
waiting for response in the giant box if
it would be great if you could tell me
if you have signed up
as a one or maybe yes in the chat box
thank you rizvana
thanks abhilash good suraj
okay so getting the access while signing
up
would let you uh go ahead with
us in the session thanks bonham good
great okay so now i would want to pass
it on to
uh the ceo find biotech elia brodsky
over to you india all right thank you
very much
and welcome everyone to our session
today
i want to go quickly over several
aspects of this program so that we can
hear from our research fellows that are
joining
and also those that are working on their
projects so as we move along i want to
introduce you to some of the key
areas that this program is designed to
address
one of the important aspects of the
research fellowship program is to enable
research and so in a lot of ways what we
try to do is we try to provide
tools and an environment where you can
effectively analyze big data access
our network of mentors and also go
through some of the training
that we provide as asynchronous online
courses
and live training which are programs so
in the next few minutes i'll introduce
you to some of these things
so that everyone knows how to benefit
from these tools
and opportunities so omits logic program
resources
combine training materials data analysis
tools that are gui based and allow you
to process big data effectively
training in coding and introduction to
research topics
using different types of omics data
these
were developed as a part of the tbi info
platform
and once you register on the learn
omixlogic.com portal
you essentially get access to both of
these portals
and platforms on the portal itself
you will find that the key area is to
complete your profile and the reason for
that is because all of the information
is going to be stored there so you can
see that you can update your profile
picture
social media you will start tracking
your achievements
and activity and you will find all of
the information about the program
right here down on the bottom so this is
the research fellowship program
so if you don't have a badge and you've
already joined
that means that you have not been added
to the program
once this profile is complete you can
always navigate to the different
programs that we have
and find other opportunities for you to
continue and explore
different areas for example right now we
have a program that's running on
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
that include specific
courses access to zoom interactive
sessions like today
and provides you with a sense of
community because we
offer a slack channel where you can
communicate directly with the mentors
as well as those that would like to
participate in a one-on-one session you
can request a session with your mentor
now those of you that still don't have
that badge please reach out to marketing
at pine.bio and sonalika who introduced
the program we'll add you to the program
once you're inside the program you will
go to your profile tab
and find there the different programs
that you're enrolled in for example
as you can see introduction to
bioinformatics transcriptomics or
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
and you can track your progress
in that program by completing individual
sessions
importantly we have a set
of points which is a system that we
designed
so that we can track your progress and
give you a sense of where you are
related to where you should be to be
able to start an independent project so
i'll talk about that in a little bit
for those of you that are part of the
research fellowship you
can reach out to us many of the sessions
are going to be available to you for
free
and some of them will require a payment
but you can reach out to us
about that so another thing that i
wanted to ask all of you to do
is to expand our network we have a group
on social media on linkedin and on
facebook so
if you uh i will paste the links if you
are a part of the research fellowship
already
we invite you to join these social media
groups and if you are not a part of them
yet
then you can also mention that you are
going through this fellowship this
allows us to see in our met
in our network those of you that are
members and those of you that are
mentors
and connect you in the future
so the other thing i mentioned is that
we have
a basic training resource where you can
use
introduction to bioinformatics
coursework
coursework on genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics
epigenomics and data science all you
need to do
is go to the omixlogic portal
and find a course that is interesting to
you
or that matches your level so
what you can do is if you see under your
profile again
you should have a basic subscription or
it should say
starter if you are a part of the
research fellowship already
it should say starter so let me show you
what that looks like
again this is important to check because
you're going to be
seeing different coursework that is
premium and so all of you have access to
the free courses once you sign up
the free option is just sample a lot of
the coursework
but those of you that have either paid
for a research fellowship already
or you were granted a scholarship
through the louisiana biomedical
research network
you will get a starter subscription
which gets you
into courses that are premium so those
that have
a star next to them you will find those
i'll just give you an example so you
will find
the courses with the star those are
accessible only for those that have a
starter subscription so make sure that
you have that accessible if you don't
reach out to marketing and find bio and
we will help set that up for you
now another important opportunity that
the omixlogic portal and the community
provides is access to these
specific webinars that are free for all
so if you have joined
our community you can gain access to all
of the free webinars and we have
regularly maybe two or three webinars
a week that you can join and benefit
from
some introduction to a topic or an
expert that speaks about a variety of
topics so these include
training programs and it also includes
the psionics club
it is a club that is operated by one of
our research fellows or
fellows ruth b vajja and she
is going to be sending invitations to
all of you that are interested
about how to register for that club
those of you that are research fellows
can also
join those sessions to talk about your
completed projects
now importantly on the portal we don't
have just
courses we also offer project examples
so the project examples are essentially
papers
that have been digested and translated
into tutorials that you can follow
performing the same analytical steps and
getting to the same outputs as described
in the paper and so this is
a way to get started with your research
topic
you can find a paper that is most
relevant to either the data type that
you have
or a topic that you're interested in to
learn about that
and try to perform similar analysis a
lot of that
is going to be done on the t by one for
platform so once you have signed up
on the learn omix logic portal you will
get
a demo account on the big data analysis
platform
so because all of you are here i want to
just quickly try this if you already
created
a profile let's navigate to
server
that t-bio that info
and please try to log in and if you can
log in with your account
you will see your email address right
here
so if you're able to do that please let
me know in the chat
so i know that you can log in because
we're going to be
using this throughout the research
fellowship and so if you're just getting
started today
by creating an account you should be
able to access this portal as well
thank you faria
okay especially for those of you that
are joining today for the first time
this is why
we want to check this today if you do
not have access to this
then you need to reach out to us and let
us know and we will look into it
excellent okay thank you everyone for
sharing that
so let me briefly talk about why
the research fellowship and what is
essentially the objective of this
research fellowship
so i'm excited to okay etoria
itaria if you have an invalid email
and password please share that with
sonalika by email
and maybe share a screenshot
okay so the research fellowship is an
opportunity to
access all of these opportunities
together
get the training that you need and start
working
on an independent project so here are
some examples of
previous participants that have gone on
to publish
have gone on to present their research
at different types of
poster sessions and also even lead as a
mentor themselves
training others from what they have
learned and so as you think about how
others have gotten to that stage let's
break it down so that we have
a step-by-step sense of how you could go
about choosing a project developing that
idea
into something that you can execute in
your
free time and then present your findings
in front of your peers the first step
is obviously to select a topic so when
you think about
a research project one of the critical
things
is to start off with an impactful topic
that
you would be interested in and that
others would be interested in
but also something that actually could
be done
with data that is available so as we go
through this process i will guide you
through some
practical steps that you can take to
identify the specific topic
then think about the audience presenting
and asking them
whether this is something that they
would be interested in and then finding
a data set
that you can actually work on during
this research fellowship
program a lot of times
getting started means following experts
and so what we offer for you to get
started and get a sense of how things
work and this is where i believe
all of you should get started with are
some practical examples on a variety of
topics that are available
already on the learnomicslogic.com
portal
these include projects that cover a
variety of data types
a variety of analytical methods and a
variety of applications of
bioinformatics to solve
problems in biomedical research in the
clinic
as well as biotechnology and even
agriculture and so as you look through
some of the projects that we have
already available
this should give you some ideas about
what
you can do in your own time
now importantly you want to get to a
stage where you
take what you've learned through your
training
and start developing your own
independent project
and so that process starts from
literature review
a lot of times you can see a particular
general topic and then go through making
that topic
a lot more specific by going through
literature reviews so in literature you
will identify gaps and answer
questions controversy and debate to
identify
that specific focus for you to work on
your independent project
ultimately that helps you define your
question and
hypothesis and what you will do
throughout the meetings that we have as
a part of the research fellowship
is go through this process of presenting
what you have learned about
then talking about your general topic
and the background as well as what you
have found in literature
and then defining that research question
or hypothesis
next you will have the time to evaluate
different data sources and data types
that we will introduce you such as
the national center for biotechnology
information and other repositories that
are more specific like
malaria gen or ncbi virus and there you
will identify
a different a project data set that you
will work on
during your research fellowship so then
the research fellowship really is broken
down
into three specific steps the first one
is introduction where you get to learn
and get introduced to the topics
evaluation where you get to develop your
research proposal
and find the reference publications and
data sets and then
as you go through the development of the
project itself you essentially apply
and practice what you have learned but
on a project of your own
now very soon we're going to be
launching this
as an interactive process on the portal
itself
that starts from what we started with
today
you will update your profile with a
good profile picture and a completed
profile where you can update your
information about you and connect to
social media
then you will have a goal and that
practical goal
will get you focused on achieving the
type of expertise that you need to work
on an independent project
and then we will offer you a course that
actually guides you through the steps
on how to make a project that is
impactful and how to
apply rigorous research
using computational biology tools to a
particular data set
so then once you are done you will have
a chance to actually
put together that project on your
profile
and it will be added so that anyone can
see
what you have been working on what is
the data set that you've used
what are the tools and the methods that
you have done and
see your whole project presentation
right there on your profile
including a video presentation and the
description of all of the methods
so we will guide you through steps like
creating a profile on github
posting there the curated data set
description that you have found for the
data set you've used
we will talk about how to describe the
methodology that you use
in your research and eventually you will
also
add there a set of scripts
that you've used and others can see and
maybe use
themselves so this is a little overview
of what that will look like
in the end and to understand
how that all fits in with the process of
this research fellowship
i want to mention some general steps
that we will go through which include
comprehension
and analysis where you have to explore
the data
and really understand what the data
could be used for
investigation where you get to practice
your critical thinking
and asking questions translating them
into technical set of criteria that you
can apply
to get rigorous research results and
then
practice writing editing and preparing
the project for submission and an
important part
is to be able to present this both to
your mentor and to the community
which we have joining this session today
so ultimately you will go through these
10 defined steps that we think will
guide you
to an excellent outcome and we have some
experience
getting others to get to that point so
step one
you will identify a topic by conducting
literature review
step two you will identify a data set
reference publications and define a
project question or focus of your
research
step 3 you will make a table of metadata
for your data set to include group names
number of samples and type of data in
each data set
on step 4 you will conduct exploratory
analysis such as pca
summary statistics or general
visualization and share the results with
your mentor by email or on slack
to get feedback and discuss analysis
steps
step 5 you will conduct data analysis
which will be
in depth and prepare all of the results
in a presentation
then you will review biological
databases and literature
comparing your results with other
findings and identifying
what part of your findings are actually
novel and then address any issues that
are highlighted
on step 7 you will present to your
mentor peers and
experts for final review on step 8 you
will finalize the presentation
record it and submit the final project
for the program
and then you will help then you will get
help from our mentors to identify a
poster session an
opportunity to publish or present
for your mentor the project that you
have worked
and then you will finish by submitting
the final project on your profile
faria yes i will explain literature
review
in fact we have a whole course on
literature review that we will be
publishing soon
so that's a great question the place to
start
is to do a search on ncbi
for pubmed and finding some review
articles that you can go through
and think about what is the topic and
what are some of the questions that
people are asking about that
topic but we will turn to that later
does anyone else have any questions
about these steps
okay if you have any questions you can
put them in the chat and we'll make sure
to address them
so finally the objective your first
objective is to summarize
in a structured way your project as a
poster
so you will talk about what is the topic
and what is the objective
then you'll describe the methodology
results and conclusions or discussion
at the end now this is
something that will guarantee a positive
outcome for all of you
some of you are very dedicated and have
a lot of free time
your objective is maybe to publish for
others you will see
an opportunity to get trained and use
your skills in a meaningful way
and some of you will want to work with
others so you don't have to necessarily
work on everything on your own
sometimes it's very helpful to work with
others
so if you are in this community that's
why we also have the slack community
it's very important that you're able to
interact with others
convince others that you have a great
project to work on
and then form that collaboration now
bioinformatics is a very collaborative
kind of a discipline everybody has to
work with others so you actually have to
get to know the other people
understand how to work together and
maybe divide up the work
and then apply it in a meaningful way so
we ourselves are
oftentimes a part of a project and
we can support your project in a
meaningful way by addressing some of the
gaps that you might have
in your research so this is an example
we had a collaboration with the
university of ghana
where a whole group was dealing with
genetic diversity of malaria
in the country of ghana among different
areas in that
region and some of our team has actually
contributed to doing the analysis or
writing or even presenting the final
product
so sometimes this will be your own
independent project where you've done so
completely on your own and we have a lot
of examples
of people that have done just that and
others
actually work with other team members
and are able to collaborate so that they
can present
now after you complete your project we
also will offer you an opportunity to
get out there and be more visible in
front of
others and so here are some examples of
featured profiles that we've done for
previous participants we highlight their
achievements and submitting
their pre-prints on bioarchive we
highlight their achievements when they
actually publish
and we have a number of people that are
publishing
including undergraduate students and
even high school students
and we even work with people that are
already in research
and so they're able to utilize the
training that they get
to really make more from bioinformatics
components
in their research and that includes
people that are
in different universities as phd
students master's students
but also high school students as well so
all of these examples i hope that we're
showing you today
as examples of those that have done
similar
things like what you want to do today
and
as you go through the process of the
fellowship
these are some of the critical
guidelines that we provide you with
so that you can be more effective now
let me briefly introduce you we do have
beyond the research fellowship meetings
that are going to be like this today we
have a whole set of summer research
mentors that could offer you help and
guidance
in making your project more successful
and helping you
get to a research result that is more
impactful for you depending on what you
want to do with these
project ideas that you have right now
and so you already probably met dr
harpreet kaur she has a phd in
bioinformatics she's an
international author on many
publications a reviewer
and an expert in cancer biology so if
anyone has
those kinds of projects i think she's
the best person to help you now she's
going to be helping
most of you in any case so if you have
any technical
questions or if you want some guidance
she would be the first person to turn to
besides dr harpreetka or we have a
number of other mentors
that we will be able to introduce you to
once you have
a good presentation to share so once you
your presentation has the exploratory
data analysis the topic
your plan for analysis maybe even some
preliminary results
that's when we can potentially match you
with a mentor
based on where you are what are your
objectives
and whether they have the expertise that
you need and we have dr persona
vasudevan who is professor and a program
director and expert in systems medicine
but very passionate about teaching
and helping other students get to where
they want to be
clinton cunha who has a double master's
degree both in molecular medicine and in
bioinformatics
dr g pauliano chavez he is a phd in
bioinformatics and expert in
neurodegenerative diseases
as well as glioblastoma sahil sethi who
is the phd student in bioinformatics but
also has a master's
in health informatics and is an expert
on big data in covid and health
disparities as well as dr laura harris
who is a program director
and a phd in bioinformatics and an
expert in microbiology so
we do have this great community of
mentors this community of mentors
continues to grow
but to be able to work of these people
you have to first complete your initial
project presentation and you will see
some of those examples today
now ultimately what we hope will happen
during the summer
is that most of you will get to a place
where your project
is presentable and that's why august
21-22
we're going to have our omix research
symposium in this research symposium
we're going to be talking about the
cutting edge research and applications
of bioinformatics and we'll have some
guest speakers to speak about that
we'll talk about different opportunities
for undergraduate masters and phd
programs in bioinformatics
we will have their recruiters and who
will speak about industry
internships and job opportunities for
those of you that are looking to develop
a career in bioinformatics
we will talk about effective resources
for training and education for those of
you
that are involved at different
universities and those of you that are
part of student communities that could
benefit from that
and we will have prizes for best high
school college and citizen science
research projects so that's an
opportunity to
earn some money expand your network and
highlight what you have done over the
summer so again i
welcome all of you to join our social
media groups and stay in touch
also continue to monitor our emails we
send a lot of emails from sonorico who
will be sharing opportunities for
training and for different opportunities
like this one
and we also have a youtube channel that
highlights some of those sessions that
are going to be helpful for you
okay so um uh i will just address
uh quickly victoria's question
she's saying what if i want to learn in
multiple fields which i have deficiency
like
metagenomics chemo informatics
methylation analysis if i'm restricted
to one project am i going to have the
chance to learn all the fields i'm
hoping to learn
so that's why i mentioned that we have
these asynchronous courses
you can go through those independently
we have
training programs you can always join
the first few sessions to learn about
that program
and if that's something you're
interested in you can reach out to us
and you will have access to some of that
or you can join the full program with
certification for
a separate registration fee and you have
the opportunity to work
in the research fellowship for three
months or six months which gives you
enough time to work on one project and
get it done
and then potentially if you want to work
on other projects you can join those as
well
so it's really up to you okay so now i
want to pass it on to dr mohit mazumdar
and dr harpreet kahr to guide us for the
rest of the session
and explain how
all of you that are joining for the
first time can start off by introducing
yourselves
thank you
thank you here hello everyone
so uh my name is uh mohith and
uh i've been working on bioinformatics
projects for a while now so i did my phd
in computational biology
and uh i during that time i've been able
to work on
several grants that were addressing
some of the key objectives uh like i got
i got to work on grants from department
of um
department of science and technology
department of energy
and uh also grants from nih and uh
also some of them were from japan and
industry
so all of those international you know
objectives
that were defined in those grants uh
where to lead to some translational
work which was one of the objective for
me to
[Music]
do so uh
second yeah thank you so
um so during that time i learned a lot
and then i
i signed up for a company to work on
to work on bioinformatics projects for
pharma and during that time so let me
just share my screen just a second
so during that time i got to learn about
how pharma is utilizing these resources
and bioinformatics resources and uh
that actually is influencing
a lot of their drug discovery pipelines
and that
is actually helping them to shorten the
whole
drug discovery timeline and also save a
lot of money
so they were into it and a lot of data
science is being involved in
pharmaceutical research and that also
like goes into the clinical trials data
management all of that
so here uh i've been uh working with uh
students and the universities and uh
and research groups so with all that
experience
my objective is to help you all come up
with project ideas whosoever is coming
up with project ideas to develop
that project idea into a project real
project
as well as uh for those who are coming
up
as uh without our background of
bioinformatics so
to start from the very basics and
understand where to start from
uh how to begin where to find
information where to find data which
courses to take
all of that so in this during this time
i've been also working with as i said
universities to develop courses so
universities
and faculties who wants to implement
this these courses and teach them
to their students and
all of that so we have have all these
programs running in different places
so today i just wanted to tell you a
little bit about uh
what i did also during my phd was
related to machine learning and
uh here we are working with several
types of data sets
that are available publicly and one of
the biggest advantages
in today's world is that there's so much
of information which is available
uh openly and that is also due to the
fact that uh
many of these uh publications requires
an open access
to data and that makes us uh you know
all uh applicable to do some new
research
on these data sets that have not been
explored fully because they contain so
much of information and
there are so many connections that uh
that different types of data sets
have and so exploring those and coming
up with projects and working on those
projects
to come up with some of the solutions
like patient stratification in the sense
of clinical
research and then how you can use that
information for disease classification
diagnostics
and then response to therapies which is
precision medicine so one of these
things that we
that we have been working on and uh we
are also
uh creating lessons and courses
so that you can go through this entire
process and
understand that how i mean from a data
set
how you can come up with all these i
mean uh
discovery terms like biomedical
discovery uh toxicity finding the
toxicity
drug targets identification a molecular
mechanism of action drug repurposing and
repositioning all of these scientific
research that you see that many uh
public
many good labs are publishing you are
also capable of doing it by exploring
the data
and utilizing some of the tools that
that we have
that we have put together for you so
there are seven types of projects that
you that you think of uh when you are
thinking about uh bioinformatics and
that is so exciting at the same time
because
uh because you get an opportunity to
work on several aspects right you work
from
work on sequences you work on special
characteristics of those sequences
features
like uh different research data has
different
sort of features some are age dependent
some are time dependent
some are location dependent so all of
those things
makes it like a variety of things to
look at
and that actually this
multi-disciplinary field gives
that holistic understanding from coming
from different types of data
is actually maybe something
that is an ultimate goal of ours to
understand everything right
system biology how the system works so
um that's integration of data and
something that
we are working with and obviously
biomarker discovery for former
former projects and we have had examples
on on glioblastoma we will have a
session
uh on the triomics that india said which
will be about also biomarker discovery
so then we have this opportunity from
you know finding solutions
so first we have to identify the problem
so we started
with basic understanding of what it is
what the technology is
how to apply the technology by itself by
learning through examples
and then you come up with your own
research project and you find the
find the problem okay this is the
problem this is the protein i mean this
is the
uh this is the gene now what to do with
it
i mean how to how to make it uh not do
what it is doing uh incorrectly
so in that sense where the strategy
comes in
the gaming information comes in there's
molecules molecules comes in
so that's what one of those aspects of
what pharma works
on pharma works on and how machine
learning is applied
into this so these are some of the
applications and similarly
i mean in the context of how
bioinformatics can be applied and as i
was telling you that
it's very exciting because because
there's so many aspects like you can
look at the networks like
how they are communicating amongst each
other so
you can draw networks amongst i mean
even within protein you can draw a
network for the atom interaction and how
they are interacting and
how the structural changes are making
that you know
differ from one state to another
similarly network analysis
can be done for uh sequel at a sequence
level to understand
disease patterns and biological systems
and
similarly like all of these things like
are exciting fields
and lets you to discover new new things
and those new things are available
for you to discover uh but yeah
obviously
you would need to go to a
way i mean we what we do is that we
follow a lot of publications
and we try to translate them into
something that is more understandable
for everyone for students
and to be able to come up with their own
research
so uh i would also like to invite you
for this
upcoming free webinar which is on june
23rd
um uh sorry not june 23rd this is uh
this is wrong so june 25th it is it is
on june 25th
that's the correctness yeah
so on friday we have the webinar and i'd
like to invite you for the session also
and uh we have uh
mentors as elia have already shown you
that so as i was telling you like
one of the outcomes of these sort of uh
doing
going to this uh research process is to
be able to come up with
uh experience research experience and
maybe
like if it's all if you go through this
entire process and find results that are
that are really interesting you uh you
can come up with
something uh like a publication also in
a very short period of time that is
possible
so this is what we have experienced so
far working together
with the uh with many smart and very
hard-working students who want to do
really well to apply this and come up
with
these research project
so i would uh now like to uh
maybe invite uh dr harpreet
so that we can also hear from some of
the participants who are working and
right now
you know working on these projects and
going through this entire experience
and i mean you can you can always like
write to me and feel free to ask any
questions that you have i will
look into the chat so now i'll just uh
invite dr harpreet to uh
okay thank you doctor thank you dr maher
so uh so can you just make me cohost
yes
thank you
so hello everyone my name is harpreet
kaur and i have a phd in bioinformatics
and i have done my master's in molecular
biology and biochemistry
and i am always interested in analyzing
those molecular mechanisms
in human disease or different human
disease
condition especially the cancer so since
as we know there is a continuously
enormous
ngs data being generated from the
patient
so i believe one can analyze such data
to understand biological
and molecular processes that is taking
place
in underlying specific disease
conditions so i joined my phd
at csiro institute of microbial
technology
and i have done my phd in the field of
liver cancer
so my phd research was on biomarker
discovery for the diagnosis
and the prognosis of the liver cancer
using bioinformatics
so with the pine biotech currently i am
curriculum developer and research
consultant and i am mentoring number of
the research follow
so i'm looking forward to work with you
now i think
we should start with the our uh
uh presentation uh maybe uh
sonalika we can proceed with the
presentation from the research followers
no
yeah yes ma'am thank you so much dr
harpreet uh before we start with the
presentations we have a
few new research fellows with us i would
want them quickly to introduce
themselves so
we know about them so can i have a donna
can you please introduce yourself to us
hi donna you can unmute yourself
okay so donna is not available maybe uh
abilash can you please
yes yes i can go and use myself yes
thank you
okay okay
and now i'm studying a master degree in
microbiology
and my thesis will be on viruses and
studying ngs data
and using nanobore as a technique uh
to study a whole genome sequencing of
this
this virus and actually i'm interested
in
i'm interesting in studying
in studying bioinformatics related for
drug discovery and
and for infectious disease
okay thank you so much tana it was good
to know about you and your research
interest
abirash can you please introduce
yourself
uh hello my name is i'm a phd student at
south korea school of mines
and i'm currently working on meta
genomics and transcriptomic
analysis of sorry um
sorry to interrupt here it would be
great if when you're introducing
yourselves and so nika maybe you can do
this as well
turn on your video it would be nice to
kind of have a face behind the name
thank you yeah hi my name is avidas i am
a phd student at south dakota school of
and currently i am working on
metagenomics
and metatranscriptomics analysis of
selfish reducing biofilms basically
about biofilms whiskey road metals
yeah and i in this uh research
fellowship program i am
interested in learning more about coding
to use
to analyze military as of currently i
use galaxy online platform but i want to
use
r and python to analyze my data that's
why i have joined this program
thank you thank you so much abhinash uh
hi eman can you please introduce
yourself next
hi i'm i'm opening hi
um um i am inventory an assistant
professor of medical genetics working
now in tulane university school of
medicine department of surgery
i was graduated from medical school had
master
and doctor degrees in medical genetics
and then i had a diploma degree in
bioinformatics but it was
very uh basic a and i didn't go in depth
into genomics transfer atomics and big
data analysis
my research uh interest is cancer
bioinformatics but actually i started to
be fond of bioinformatics since 2014
when there was no available sources in
my home country so i started self
learning and attending workshops and
learn
a bit r coding for visualization is to
capture as much as i can i applied what
i learned in peer-reviewed publication
that was useful
and that's great job from your side that
all what we have are going to be
learning is to be in publications and
posters
in something vulnerable as well and
therefore um
i felt there is a need for machine
learning as well i started to know more
about bipin coding i'm not perfect in
any of these what i mentioned now
i am trying and i want to learn more as
it shouldn't says
there are available public repositories
in big data and that needs to be
going more in depth to unravel um
to find new discoveries from these
hidden genomic in terms of atomic
signature
so i joined here the course in order to
have a more comprehensive view
more analysis to share uh to expand my
network with other bioinformatics and
share experience with them and to
achieve
more and to enjoy diving and exploration
together with my beers
i want um to discover more about drug
discovery metrogenomics methylation
analysis
and gos analysis i want to learn all the
tools that i come up
with i come across with the
bioinformatics
so i'm hoping during the six-month
course of the
this fellowship that um i upgrade myself
in this field and teach others as well
my campus and my home country
thank you again guys thank you very much
nice to have you here
thank you thank you amen looking forward
to your work
uh faria can i have you next please
um
yes your audible first hello ma'am
hello yes faria you're audible yes i am
a resident of jeddah saudi arabia i'm
currently doing bsc biotechnology from
delhi damian university
and i'm just a student right now so i am
i have participated in research
fellowship program to
explore more on cancer or
alzheimer's disease
thank you faria it is nice to know about
your
interest saying can we have your next
piece
uh hello am i am i audible yes your
audience thank you
okay okay yeah so uh my name is poonam
sen
and uh i have done masters in plant
science and
masters in international relations and
uh i'm from india
right now i'm working as a botany
faculty
here in india so i have joined or i have
i've also like
recently joined the pine biotic research
fellowship
and i don't have much exposure to
computational biology so i'm
very much excited to learn from all of
you
my research interests are basically
plant molecular biology
and stress response and uh i want
i also want to explore about the
epigenetic regulations
and uh yeah so that's
my intro thank you so much
thank you thank you thank you uh rucha
are you ready with your presentation
uh yeah i am yes so i've given you the
access to please share your screen
over to youtube you can start with your
presentation
okay if you could also if you could also
please start with a brief
introduction about yourself so others
can get to know you and
if you don't have the option turn on
your video that would be great
uh yeah sure um i'll do that but the
thing is my camera there's a problem
with it so um
please just this time no problem
so okay yeah so i'll be sharing my
screen now
uh is my screen visible yes it is
okay so uh hello everyone uh my name is
rocha koneti
and i'm from bangalore india so i'm
currently studying biotechnology at
ramaya
institute of technology so i've
previously done
molecular docking studies on drug
resistant tuberculosis
and saskof2 but i've always been
interested in
how we can use genomics or
transcriptomics and
in in the analysis of various diseases
uh so uh that's why i joined this
research fellowship program and i'm
really glad i got a chance to
participate
so today i'll be sharing with you
uh what project i chose to do
and that's alzheimer's disease so
alzheimer's is a neurodegenerative
disorder
and it affects individuals over uh
60 years of age or in people with
trisomy 21
and commonly the symptoms include
dementia and other non-cognitive
symptoms like delusion or agitation etc
and neuropathologically and this is the
most important thing
uh there are formation of uh beta
amyloid
uh aggregates and uh the top protein
uh deposition uh this is why
uh the disease is caused mostly because
of these deposition
so
so that is why i chose my data set as uh
from this bio project this project may
uh consider
uh non-demented control brains
and area brains containing only the
amyloid beta plaques or
both the plaques and the tau pathology
so so currently
uh what happens when amyloid beta and
pathology increases
in the brain is unknown so
that is why this project
was probably done and so this project
identified two types of
microglia that is 81 and 82 associated
with ad
and so 81 was associated with
the amyloid beta flux and 82 microglia
were
abundant with the top pathology
brains uh so identifying these microglia
might
help us like tell us more about uh
how exactly ad is cause and why
so based on this uh
i chose to do the chose to do my project
and so here there are uh
two types of samples uh oligodendrite
and neuronal cell samples taken from two
regions of the brain occipital cortex
and the occipital temporal cortex or the
fusiform gyrus
and these types of cells were identified
by their biomarkers that is the all it
to transcriptional factor
and the neuronal biomarker respectively
so from in both these cell samples there
are
uh three types of groups there is ad
ctr and ctr plus ctr is basically the
control samples
uh ctr uh samples uh
have no amyloid plaques
are top protein deposition as seen here
and cr plus have uh the amyloid plaques
but no top deposition so
the difference between this and 80
is that although they have the amyloid
deposition
uh these brains are not demented
but in 80 there is a distinct dementia
that was observed so
uh and then of course in ad there is
both amyloid and third opposition
so uh coming to my
data set uh there were 15
samples totally uh consisting of the
oligodendrite
and the neuron neuronal samples and in
each
uh there were ctr ctr plus and 80
as shown here so and uh
coming to my research questions what i
want to ask was
uh how the ad and control groups are
different from
each other in both the cell types and
later on i would like to identify like
you know
gene expression in the oc and otc
regions of the brain
in both the cell samples among the three
groups
so first i did a pca
among the cell samples and this is what
i got
the red dots clustered together show the
neuronal
cell samples and the blue dots
show the oligodendrocytes and
this pc1 versus pc2 indicate a 62
percent of the total variance
and then i did a
pca among uh
the three different groups in both the
cell samples
so on the left you can see
oligodendrocyte or
pca and on the right you can see a
neuronal pca
and so here uh
you can see in the oligodendrocytes that
uh this is pc1 versus pc3
showing a total of 40 percent of the
variance and the red dots are clustered
together here that is the 80 samples
the green dots are here that is the
control samples with no amyloid beta
plaques
and the ctr with amyloid
beta plaques are shown in the blue dots
similarly you can see
for the neuronal samples so i've done
till here
i'd like to know what i can do further
on thank you
everyone for listening
thank you for sharing and
because first thing you need to
understand based on this uh
pca plot what are the different outliers
um can you
i mean in the first part if we look at
there are the two outliers
like the green one and this blue one and
that is
control because i still uh to me it is
still not clear it looks like
ctr plus is actually uh maybe we can say
it's like a
phase where this pathology starts or the
beta plates just start
uh getting accumulated something like
that right yes ma'am
it may be i i mean this is the control i
don't understand like control
simple control must be the normal sample
so here uh looks like that
may be the control plus samples it's
like where you just start
beta plate start getting accumulated
okay so
maybe now what you can do okay so the
first thing you need to do
remove these two outliers if look it
looks like
uh maybe this green one uh
not this one i mean on the left side
left side this one each one
yeah this one this uh and this and now
one at the top that is blue one that is
okay yeah
it's probably it looks like these are
the outliers and maybe first thing that
you need to do
for uh particularly if you're dealing
with this data that is oligodendroids
oligodendro dendrites
yes so i think first you need to remove
that and maybe need to run pca
again and then uh you can find out what
are the differentially expressed genes
between
uh maybe here you can ask two types of
questions control versus ad
and ctr versus ad ctr plus sorry
ctr plus words and this is the first
thing that you need to look at like what
are the
uh significant genes or maybe what are
the important genes that can actually
uh differentiate these two groups so we
need to identify
the transcriptional changes at the first
stage okay so i have to do differential
uh expression man yeah using d6
yeah i do remember in your data it is
already you have read count value
so the next you need to prepare your
data set to run desect analysis
maybe here you can actually compare
multiple groups at the first
just to understand whether you actually
have you know
some important significant genes that
can distinguish these glasses of the
samples
okay and then let's see how what you are
getting out of that
and now i just want uh ilia must add his
points here
yeah yeah i just wanted to ask again so
rucha what is
the specific question that you're trying
to answer with this analysis
um i want to know how uh like this
data set considers uh
two different brain regions so i want to
see how the genes are expressed in those
regions
among the different groups here but why
um because that's where uh
the plaques and the top protein
deposition occurs
most often that that is a neuropathology
right so i think that's the point that
i'm trying to make is you
need to think about what is the specific
question so if you go back to
i think your second slide
so what happened was you introduced
yourself and then you told us
yeah maybe uh where where's okay so
this is a background about alzheimer's
disease
yeah and now you have a specific
question so as you explore this
data set and hopefully you've done some
literature review
link your analysis to some important
question that is still
unanswered about alzheimer's disease so
think about
why would you do all of this analysis
how will the results of the analysis
help you answer that question
once you get a set of differentially
expressed genes for example
why are they important and what will you
find what will
be the potential impact of what you're
doing with this
okay okay okay i'll do that
and you can see uh someone is writing in
the chat hitoria
uh so we have three groups and you can
make pairwise analysis and
and find the intersecting gene so before
you even go down
to the steps of you know what other
people are suggesting
you always have to think of what is your
objective why are you doing what you're
doing
and where will that lead you to after
that
i think in the next session just a
couple more observations
um we want to know a little bit more
about why you selected alzheimer's
disease
as your topic of interest and when you
present this
present it as if you are presenting to
collaborators
so all of us here on the session we want
you
to succeed and we want you to do
something meaningful with your time
so how can we help you can we help you
by
uh making suggestions about
bioinformatic analysis
can we help you by focusing your
attention on some
important question that you could answer
with your research
could we maybe guide you to another
project that somebody else is working on
that maybe combining the two
will make your project more impactful
right
we want to know how can we help you as
we're listening to this
and when you get to a point that you
don't know what to do
it has to be connected to where you
started so
you said okay so i did it up until now
now i don't know what to do next
right so let's yeah yeah you should from
the beginning
say that's what you should announce i
have
done my literature interview i have done
my exploratory data analysis
and now i am at a place where i'm
starting to identify this
specific analysis question that i will
focus on
right and that's what you should get
okay okay i'll do that yeah
okay okay thank you very much
thank you so much alia and dr harpreet
for all these suggestions
now i would want to invite our research
fellow dhruv
uh to please uh share his research
project or what do you think
hello everyone i hope i'm audible and
visible
yes you are okay
is my screen visible yes
thank you so hello everyone uh my name
is jamiro
and today i'm going to present the
progress of my research project
called transatomic analysis of useful
carcinoma
so a quick introduction uh my name is
john mehra
and i'm a graduate in medical
biotechnology so i graduated last year
from america university
and at present i'm working as a research
fellow at pine biotic
and talking about my past experiences
i've
worked as an intern in research in
sangha department of the precision
medicine company
and there i used to work along with my
team on
projects related to genomics and
molecular diagnostics
and other than that i have actually uh
worked
as a histopathology intern in a
government on school here in india
and talking about my research interest i
am interested in precision medicine
cancer biology genomics and transgenics
and
through this fellowship i'm expanding my
horizons in the field of data science
so before starting i'll just introduce
my
uh topic so
esophagus esophagus is actually a
muscular organ that finance
failings to the stomach and esophageal
carcinoma is actually a malignant
neoplasm of these hypotheses
and the condition is actually associated
with tobacco use alcohol consumption
and deficiency of vitamin a b 3 and c
along with that there are several health
conditions associated with the disease
such as esophagitis celiac disease and
good
so talking about the epidemiology so
these figures are from the who
cancer repository these figures are from
year 2020 and in that year there were
like 600 000 cases of esophageal cancers
and the mortality rate was somewhere
around
540 000 and uh talking about the
geographical distribution
uh asian population has actually uh
reported the maximum number
of incidents and these figures are
actually quite surprising as uh it
indicates the
need for near therapeutic diagnostic and
prognostic approaches
for the management of the disease and
that was the major
motivation for me to you know undertake
this project
before defining my hypothesis i just
explained my data set
so for this uh project i've actually
used the pcga
esophageal carcinoma dataset and the
dataset actually consists of 198 samples
out of this 13 are normal samples and
there are 185 tumor samples
and like these are my
preliminary hypothesis so by this
research project i want to attain two
major objectives
so first is to know more about the gene
signatures involved in concept operation
and second is to look for gene
signatures or biomarkers associated with
prognosis of the disease and here is
also
an analysis plan which i've been
following so i started by preparing my
data set so
i match my metadata with the expression
data and then i remove
i took the average of the duplicate
genes and then i proceed
with the pca and today i'm here to
present the
results of my bge analysis
so uh this is a actually a pca
uh from my for like uh you know
when i was undertaking my objective one
so
uh i actually divided my data set into
as per the stages
so there was like normal um there was
stage one stage two stage three and
stage four
and uh surprisingly i actually got these
two clusters
which were uh you know quite surprising
for me so there is cluster one
on the right and there is cluster one on
the left and then i
uh looked into this cluster formation
and it turns out to be that these two
are the
histological subtypes of the esophageal
carcinoma
so uh like uh in the species like on
your right is the esophageal scrum
cell carcinoma and uh on your left is
the esophageal adrenal carcinoma
and like the normal is diffused in
between
so before like going i just quickly
described these two subtypes
so uh esophageal sphamma cell carcinoma
so it's a malignant epithelium a tumor
with squamous cell differentiation
so uh actually spharma cell cells
actually forms the innermost lining
of these surfaces uh also the like the
epithelium and in this cancer subtype uh
that epithelium the spammer cells are
actually
affected and they form the tumor
and uh like uh
in the esophagus the middle third like
the this
isophysics paracel carcinoma is
localized to the middle third of the
esophagus
and is associated with uh factors like
tobacco use
uh alcohol abuse and micronutrient
deficiency
and likewise we have esophageal ignore
carcinoma
which is actually the uh malignant tumor
of these surfaces with
glandular tissue involvement so this is
uh
somewhat different from the survival
muscle carcinoma because it is uh
associated with a condition called
barrett's esophagus so barrett esophagus
is actually a premium plastic condition
uh in which the squamous cells are uh
actually converted into the glandular uh
scientist type of tissue uh
which leads to the uh further
aesophageal ignore carcinoma
so uh here is a figure of the process of
carcinogenesis
so first uh we have the uh isopropyl
from the cell phase number
so this is the normal epithelium and
the uh like it is continuously insulted
by alcohol tobacco and thermal injury
which leads to the subsequent faces of
carcinogenesis so like
there's farmers hyperplasia spammers
dysplasia
and this which further results in
full-blown reciprocals from the cell
carcinoma
and likewise we have the second
substrate so
like the normally epithelium then it's
converted into the
esophagus because of the insult of the
bile and the acid reflux
also are leading to transversions
subsequently leading to
the carcinogenesis like there are
conditions
this plastic uh barrichesophagus and
then to the esophageal
adenocarcinoma
uh there was like uh during my
uh review literature review i actually
find
found something uh really interesting
about the these cancer subtypes
so uh like in the graph a
is actually reported it was seen that
majorly the developed nations have
reported this
cancer type and it was opposite for the
case
of esophageal islamosas carcinoma all
the developing nations
uh have been reporting the cases of
piece of pigeons commercial customer
and i guess that was the reason i
couldn't
even find a single paper uh which could
actually
uh you know compare these two subtypes
and then i took my research forward and
i plotted the pca
so here is a piece here between the
normal and the separate
number so again uh two clear class
clusters so first and the second again
there are outliers
and i did the same with the second
subtype so
again two clear cut clusters first and
the second
so uh likewise i have been associated
with my differential in
expression analysis and i
i actually performed this into three sub
divisions so in the first i compared the
normal and the esophageal adenocarcinoma
and then i compared the normal versus
the esophagus from the cell carcinoma
and then i actually compared these
official adenocarcinoma
uh and the surprises from the cells so
here is the pipeline construct so for
this
differentiating expression analysis i've
actually used the d62
uh algorithm uh since i was uh you know
supplied with the royal
counts uh uh here were the
results for the differential gene
expression analysis
so uh i actually found 8745 genes which
were differentially expressed between
normal and esophageal adenocarcinoma uh
with a p
adjacent value of less than 0.05 uh
then uh you know to see about the
up regulation or the down regulation of
the gene i set up a
log fc cutoff so uh i found
1473 genes which were upregulated
uh and there were eighteen hundred
uh zero eighteen hundred eight beans
which were down regulated
both like the log fc was uh greater than
one point five in case of object related
and
for the case of down related it was less
than 1.5 or minus 1.5
and there is actually a volcano plot
describing the
results so volcano plot is actually a
type of scatter plot which uh
like which compares which have uh like
minus log of p adjusted value on the y
axis and the log fault chain on the x
axis so uh the one
the dots in the red are actually
differential differentially expressed
beams
and we are actually uh interested in the
red dots here which are the uh up
regulated and the down regulated genes
and likewise i have actually compared
the other group
like the normal versus the surface is
carcinoma
and uh like i again found 10
000 more than 10 000 beans which were
differentially expressed with p
value of greater than 0.05 uh more than
2 000 uh up regulated and downright
related genes
and then uh the final one the esophageal
adenocarcinoma
and the uh esophageal spam muscle
carcinoma
so surprisingly there were 14 000 or
more than 14 000 differentially
experienced
and after setting up the log fc cutoff i
actually got 2016's
and which were up regulated and 1600
intelligence which are downregulated
i actually tried to do a comparative
analysis
so i have uh like i've actually
compared the case one with the case two
so here the case one is actually the
uh differentially expressed genes in uh
normal versus esophageal adenocarcinoma
and second case is the differentially
exposed genes
with normal versus the surfaces from
muscles
and as a result of that i've actually
got common genes so i've got 845
upregulated genes which are common both
the subtypes
and uh thousand and uh
1013 genes which are down regulated in
both the subtypes
and the reason why i did that was uh
first because i wanted to know more
about the common differential
genes which are common in both the
subtype like the this region
which is i hope the diagram is
uh visible so uh i focus on this common
reason
and the second reason being uh to look
for a
subtype specific differential
differentially expressed genes
so uh if i look at this area
so it will actually you know help in
uh better patient stratification and
maybe i can get some insights about uh
like various uh pathways involved in
subtypes which are quite specific
and for the future i'll be actually
doing a
pathway enrichment analysis and i'm
planning to conduct a more
uh comprehensive literature review uh
just to see
uh just for uh knowing the
chances of type management and maybe
after that i can uh
get some good results
[Music]
thank you
thank you so much drew for such a wonder
wonderful presentation now i would want
dr harpreet to please give the
suggestions
okay so thank you for now nice
presentation
uh and i have a few things to say
the first thing when you actually are
doing
um venn diagram so why you compared only
two
instead you because you already have two
subtypes right
instead of the two i think you have to
consider the third uh where you are
doing uh
a differential gene expression analysis
between asc and esfc
so that is the another thing but uh
because uh as i know this data was taken
from tcc itself right
so as you were mentioning about your uh
literature review because
some of the uh you know one sub type is
more
uh prevalent in developed countries and
another subtype is more prevalent in
developing country so because uh in tcca
data you also have ethnicity information
you should know what are the ac asians
or you know americans or latins
so i just want to see actually if you
look at uh you know in your samples
whether you can also compare
that part because when you are talking
about like there is a
uh difference in a even subcontinent
so that is also we need to understand
whether there is actually ethnicity is
also there
i mean all these genes or these subtypes
are associated with the
that ethnicity uh okay mom i'll
definitely look into that because uh
yeah
that information is provided
yes non-definitely because the
geographical distribution is
yeah is quite uh different for both the
subtypes
so i'll definitely look into the
ethernet city yeah i mean the another
information
there must be the rays which race they
belong to so
these factor you must consider because
when you are doing this analysis
and i thought that must be important
finally when you are actually going to
compare the things and going to
interpret these results maybe that would
be interesting to
uh understand that part okay definitely
i'll look into the
best part and i'll share my results next
week
okay thank you okay i also wanted to
mention a little bit um
so another type of a factor that is
actually
common with the surface girl cancer is
uh
abstain bar virus infection and
typically that's also reported
right oh yes sir yes so um
you know the question about the cause of
cancer is one question that you have
the other question that you might have
is what would be the treatment
another question that you might have is
early detection
yes right definitely so so all of these
factors
are there and you've done some
exploratory analysis and you just
decided you know i'm going to do now
comparative analysis of gene expression
once you do your gene expression let's
say you find some enriched pathways or
let's say you have some specific genes
that you're interested in
another question that you could ask is
how is the current
treatment of those types of patients and
you have some treatment information and
the tcga data also
is changing for esophageal cancer
because it is changing
there are some common targets for cancer
and then there are specific targets for
cancer
so i think that the place where you're
at is a good
um place to pause for a second
consider the various factors that you
have
before going down to the comparative
level you already know what to expect
but before you know what to focus on you
have to maybe
give us some idea of out of all the
factors
this is the actual difference that i'm
interested in
or maybe out of all of the potential
metadata that i have access to this is
the type of metadata that i would like
to focus on
and consider also other types of data so
you chose transcriptomic data
why just look at gene expression why not
also look at mutation data for example
or methylation data
okay so i had like i got inspired by
this uh
when i say like there is pam 50 say for
uh breast cancer which actually uh you
know
describes a lot like there is uh like
what would
the prognosis best treatment so i
thought of something very similar for
this
but uh definitely i'll look into these
points and then i'll go from there
okay and i do see how uh some five
points that
um again was in the chat
and i think that that's some you know
good feedback
iman okay it's in humans sorry i don't
know from your username
so number one why jar was written in the
workflow despite
seeing not used do we need to multiple
methodology
when we choose i think this is just a
figure from
the platform you get thousands of views
why not raise the full change
threshold for that question you know i'm
not sure
that you need to raise necessarily the
full change
i think what you need to do is
downstream analysis group them by
pathway or gene ontology
then she's mentioning maybe you reflect
risk stratification
in your objective so if it is a risk
stratification you mentioned smoking you
mentioned other factors
there's viral infection as a factor you
know it would be nice to understand
whether that is something that has
already been explored so have you read
the publication that is associated with
the whole data set
uh yes sir actually like the original
tcga
publication actually talks about the
data integration
so they have actually clapped the
transcriptomics
and the mutational data so they have
actually clustered this
uh cancer into subtypes but surprisingly
like
no one has actually compared these two
subtypes
and uh like i was actually proceeding
with that id only
well that's actually a good point maybe
you could clarify that at the beginning
so you did
review their publication and you know
that
there is a way to cluster patients but
no one really looked in depth at
a particular you know cluster and how
they that difference
also yes you did mention your pca
analysis
that these are groups or clusters maybe
you could actually do that clustering
and show us how those clusters separate
um that's a good point um okay so then
number four she's talking about in the
objective it was mentioned
in intention to compare the two cancer
types do you intend to do that with
these academic
versus squamous cancer or finding the
non-intersectional
gene list is enough so
i think here i you're doing this
comparative analysis but i think that at
the moment
it's still a little bit exploratory
because you haven't considered all the
factors like or pre-mentioned
maybe after you've done that you can
show the um
results okay so
i'll definitely look into the metadata
and
the base points and i'll share my
results next week
thank you
thank you so much drew for a wonderful
presentation
and thank you elia for the suggestions
as well uh now i would want to
call our next research fellow jeevan
jeet kaur she is from amity
university noida and she wants few
suggestions from
ilya so over to you given joke i'm
making you the course talk post you can
now share yourself
thank you mom
uh hello am i audible
yes you're audible and we can see your
screen as well okay
hello everyone i am jeevan jyotko from
amity university
and uh i'm a final year student of btech
biotechnology
and i live in india so i joined fine
biotech
for my summer internships one month
back so what i have completed is uh i
completed the genomics course
for that i have to complete the r code
also so i completed the r code one also
i run all the quotes and done all the
assignments and quizzes
uh okay sorry
am i visible
yes you are thank you
and i had gone through the following
papers uh which is
uh which is uh which
which are through my research interest
so what i basically learned is
uh actually i had learned a lot of
things like
everything is interconnected it's not
just the courses but
uh i had gone through many things i had
gone through the wikipedia going through
youtube googled many things
so uh i learned the dna structure uh and
the basic concepts related with dna
whether it's the
uh structure whether it's the uh
histones or uh
uh whether it's like trans uh
transcription and all
i had learned the r code where i learned
the loading of
data about the visualization of data
through various
histograms and heat maps also i learned
the phylogenetic tree analysis and the
variant calling
so on the basis of this uh the tentative
topic i decided was
uh with the help of my mentor herpet
call is bioinformatics approach to
analyze variance and retinitis
pigmentosa
so um what is retinitis pigmentosa first
of all
it is a heritable genetic rare rare
genetic disorder
it can be inherited through three
inheritance patterns that is autosomal
dominant autosomal recessive and
x-linked that is why i think it became
my
uh topic of interest the occurrence
probability is one is to four thousand
and in this firstly the road receptors
are affected and then the cone receptors
approx hundred genes uh are mutated uh
to cause this retinitis pigmentosa some
are mentioned here
the sources are mentioned too there are
three stages mainly
uh number one is the um night blindness
number second is there is a visual field
loss of the concentric then
it is the central vision loss and the
person becomes completely blind
so uh i came across a fact actually
uh it is almost 60 percent of causal
variants are unknown for rp till date
and um the two questions which came
across
are how mutated or absent genes result
in vision loss
and is the gene under study homozygous
or heterozygous for the disease
retinitis pigmentosu retinitis
pigmentosa in given samples
i had gone through the methodology it is
like the samples are collected and they
then the whole exam sequence is had been
performed
so after that the each sample
had gone through the variant calling
then all the vcf files are combined
and then the joint calling had been
performed
after that the variant filtering is done
and
using the plink it had been
distinguished that whether the genius
homozygous or the heterozygous
this is the presentation and now
i really want uh these suggestions uh
that how to download the data sets
or how to look for the data sets to
run the variant callings and all thank
you
okay maybe i can jump in here so if i
understand correctly
you've identified your question but you
don't really have a data set that you
found have you looked at any data sets
at all
yes sir sir i just looked for a data set
that is sra of prpf gene uh
in retinitis pigmentosa
just one gene i guess so
okay so what i would suggest and again
not having the time to kind of think and
see what's out there but i would suggest
that
first of all one gene
and the specific mutations you could
just
find on reference databases you don't
really have to do the analysis itself
so typically um you know the i mean we
can help you find some data sets but i
would say that the more
interesting question would be to first
demonstrate that this gene is in fact
the most important
and the second thing is to really try to
understand
what types of projects recently have
been done
to look into this i mean is this an
unanswered question is this something
that no one has ever asked before
or has somebody asked this and they've
come to some
results and in those results maybe
there's some contradiction or a gap
something that hasn't really been
addressed
so i think that's kind of where you are
um
and so i would do just like you did
literature if you do a review of
available data sets on this topic okay
so
the causal variants are known uh are not
known till date
like hundred genes are being uh mutated
in this and uh
uh i just mentioned that sixty percent
uh of the
causal variants are unknown so that's
why i just chose the top
topic to study more about it but if
they're unknown how do you know
it's in this one gene
okay so means uh i have to study for
genes more than one
well yeah so i mean if it's unknown so
you have
uh a disease associated with some
mutation let's say right
uh well you suspect that it's a mutation
now you're saying that i'm going to take
this one gene and i'm going to look for
everything in this gene
uh that is you know maybe associated
with the disease
i think you have to step back and you
have to ask yourself so
how does a phenotype get
how does the association genotype and
phenotype gets
found in the first place so maybe you
can say that
you know many proteins are involved in
function of a particular organ or a
tissue and here i have a disease which
is maybe some
bad function that is being affected so
your question is
why right and so what you need to have
is again just like drew presented you
have
multiple conditions maybe healthy and
sick
and then you can start asking a question
based on the comparison and groups that
i have
what are the different factors so maybe
it's a mutation
maybe it's a methylation maybe it's gene
expression
maybe it's something else so that's
where i think you are
now you took it to mutations only and
maybe that's because there's some
genetic association that is known right
that's what you were trying to say that
there's a known risk
associated with uh genetic inheritance
so
in that case maybe you need to
kind of think of a specific criteria how
do i find a data set that actually has
those kinds of factors already in the
data have you looked on ncbi for any
data sets at all
yes sir so i found it to uh
one data set only till late what is it
do you have a link
so i could share the screen for that
so may i share the screen yeah sure
okay so this is a gene expression data
set right
yes
actually it is not a gene expression
yeah
it was not gene expression data as much
as i remember
it's just your expression profiling by
hydrogen sequencing but
okay um
can you just scroll down
and here's a suggestion also a useful
suggestion from iman
she's saying um that
you know you could potentially look for
also animal
model data so like mice she's
she says that she found some geodata
sets for
humans and for mice but
i guess we are kind of going back to
that original question you know
gene expression data will give you a
sense of which genes are involved
and sometimes a gene with
a mutation is expressed
but it's not performing its function
correctly
so that could be one cause of disease
sometimes it could be that the mutation
itself
let's say a stop codon changes the full
protein
so the question is what are we really
looking for
and why and if you focus on
you know vcf files for dna
sequencing data maybe that's a good
place to start because you know that
there's
genetic inheritance and if you do that
there is a
analysis called genome-wide association
if you have enough data and here you
have
you need to have maybe hundreds at least
hundreds
of data points so whole genomes
so you can look up gus
and you know if you have
maybe hundreds of samples with genomic
data
and you can quantify the phenotype
here you need to think about what does
it mean to quantify the phenotype for
example g
was is used often times in resistance to
different drugs
so there you have each drug and
resistance full resistance partial
resistance no resistance right
so now you need to think how can you
assign numbers
so if you have a you know
set of genes and mutations and maybe
it's multiple mutations
together and you have the phenotypes the
model of g
was finds associations that are
statistically significant
i think that if this is still unexplored
there is not a
known mutation for the cause
maybe that is because there's not enough
data or maybe because this phenotype is
difficult to quantify
so maybe that's another challenge but i
think that
uh we do have a project on tuberculosis
that describes gwas in detail
so if you go and learn and you just want
to understand how
gus works and how to deal with mutations
i would suggest we have a
course on genomics uh that talks about
cancer right and
i saw that you went through that already
yes so yes so
yeah and then so g was is
a technique that again is very specific
to the type of data that you have
you have to have a lot of samples and
you have to have one defined phenotypes
and harpreet actually has worked on the
tuberculosis dataset so i think she can
explain that
and see whether that's applicable in
your project
okay thank you so
um harpreet i don't know do you want to
mention something about that
yeah i think uh i just need to i mean
yes i will discuss it with her
i mean uh because i need to understand
exactly what questions
she wants to ask so that was my maybe
i'm not able to actually get her exact
idea what she wants to work on
because uh she asked that she wants to
identify variants so that is why
i just want to make sure that we should
we should be able to understand exactly
what she what the questions she wants to
work on
because the data said i think still we
can help her to find out
but only i'm just not able to understand
exactly
what she's trying to find out uh in
their
in-heart project
but i think definitely it's a good start
right so it looks like you've
done some background analysis
you kind of identify that this is an
interesting topic for you to work on
now we need to i think quickly move on
and focus on the type of data
what what data set could you work with
yes so so it's a request as uh we are
very new to this like uh i had not gone
through any research before
so um it is like um
i'm not asking for the spoon feeding
actually but it's like uh we
we are very new like we know uh we want
to know a lot of things in this like uh
my peers also in batch too
yeah yeah so i think that's why it's
very useful
to take an example first and go through
that example
and then you understand how people have
gone from a general topic of interest
to maybe asking that specific question
when they have the data already
available
so i think that what we are trying to do
here is
before you jump to asking the question
about this new topic that you've
discovered
know how to ask the question and then
once you know how to ask the question
then you know that before you even can
ask
you know about a gene or a mutation you
need to show us that the gene or the
mutation
is the way that we should be addressing
this question that you have in mind
and um you know in my understanding
right now
you have gotten to a place where
maybe with your peers maybe with others
that are interested
in this question and maybe you can
convince them that this is a useful
question to pursue
then you can ask them let's think
together let's brainstorm let's
look on ncbi let's find other data sets
and publications
and let's come up with an interesting
question to focus on
because all of you will spend a lot of
time right
trying to work through the difficulties
and finding some answer
you want to use that time in a
meaningful way
yes so so uh do i have to look the
transcriptomics portion also for this or
uh it's just the genomics one
so i don't know anything about this
disease myself
so i can look into it myself also but i
would like to know why genomics or why
transcriptomics before i say you know go
for transcriptomics right
so i mean from the data set that you
showed it looked like it was a
response to treatment so when you treat
some cells
you can measure gene expression but
genomic data maybe is more relevant to
the cause
maybe it's a genetic inheritance so
those are two very different questions
and that's why those two different data
sets would be very different
if you want to understand the cause
you probably want to look at which genes
are significant
and then you want to go back and say
where are those mutations
causes a very difficult question in
biology
because we don't have all the
information to study the cause right
we only have some associations that we
can find
and those associations are not always
the cause there might be the effect
of something else that we don't see and
so
the cause and the mechanism are some of
the major challenges in biology
but the effect and the application are
sometimes easier because you can say
i have a treatment i have an effect i
can measure both of them
and then if i have an association maybe
i can use that in a meaningful way
or if you want to learn about something
that has to do with
you know the impact of something already
known like i know there's a mutation now
i want to understand exactly how that
works
in a specific context right those are
questions that are a little bit more
easy to address
with the data analysis itself
but in your case you know i wouldn't say
that that's to say that you shouldn't
pursue the question you've identified
sounds like an interesting topic
it's new to me i'm sure it's new to a
lot of other people
let's find out what's in there i think
that's that's the purpose here is to be
able to ask these questions
thank you sir
thank you so much and thank you so much
even jota as well
so now i think we should be ending this
meeting we had a great discussion
we discussed about our research
fellowship program and also we had a
research fellows present their work
though we have a lot of research fellows
to present but
just time is relevant and that's why we
just had a few of them
and also we have a lot of new
participants today we have a lot of new
people who want to be a part of the
research fellowship program
so i'm sharing with you all the the
registration links of the program
and you can register yourself here for
the program and if you have any doubt
then you can mail me at marketing at the
rate fine dot bio
uh iman we just take your question yes
okay so your question is if the timing
does not fit your schedule
then what right so uh yeah it doesn't
matter
so iman you can anytime schedule a one
one-on-one meeting with dr harpreet
and then discuss your uh research work
that would be better for you and these
research fellowship meetings we
basically have to discuss
the to have the presentations by a
research fellow so that also
you all get to know what's happening and
what could be done further and also you
can clear
your doubts here but you can anytime ask
your mentor to schedule one one-on-one
meeting and
meet at your time at your own time you
can have a word with dr hybrid
at support at the refine.bio
and let her know what day and time suits
you
and then she'll fix the meeting
accordingly
yes yes it would be according to your
schedule a man
i hope that uh sucks your
doubt right okay thank you and uh
for others you can register yourself on
the link i have shared
and also to learn more about the program
and also to have insights from the
work of our previous research fellows
you can visit this research fellowship
blog here
it has all the details what all would be
covered what would
what would be the process of the
research fellowship program
and also it has the sample projects and
the projects from our research fellows
are ex-research fellows
and seeing them all you can have great
insights and learn more
and also india we have people here from
lbrn group today so rizwana i would want
you to introduce yourself to us
uh hello hi rizzana yes you are audible
yes uh hello everyone i am
[Music]
yeah thank you hello everyone i am
rizwana
currently i am pursuing my master's
sorry phd degree in environmental
toxicology at southern university and a
m college baton rouge and my
dissertation project
basically focus on vaping induced
toxicity
and we basically focuses on molecular
mechanisms
uh and in that i am particularly
targeting proteosome and amino
proteosomes
these are the two cellular pathways
which are responsible to maintain
proteostasis
and in this specifically i'll be
determining the assembly of mixed
proteosome variants
with constituent and inducible subunits
and
i'm also interested to include the
rna sequencing and the chip sequencing
analysis in my
thesis so that's the reason i have
joined this
research fellowship program okay and
reswana have you created an account
today
um on learn did you create an account
yes yes okay great so if you could paste
your account
link the url from the top url
just paste it in here so that we can add
you we need to
submit it to lbrm okay
thank you thank you roswana uchechi can
you please introduce yourself next
us so i think what you can do so
can you introduce yourself please
hello um
it's uchichi oh i'm so sorry it's
yes i'm having internet issues that's
why i couldn't hear it
was perfectly fine
yes can you please introduce yourself
yes ma'am
good afternoon my name is
a senior toxicology major at the
university of louisiana monroe
i'm currently working with dr maru in
his lab where he's working with one
three diary parasols
and we're synthesizing the parabolas and
conducting biomedical research on them
for the treatments of melanoma skin
cancer
so my interest my research interest is
i'm trying to
research the field of psychopharmacology
because i've taken a lot of pre-pharmacy
classes
and um that's something i've always been
interested in i've been interested in
seeing how
the post and anti-antimatter
medications affect postpartum depression
and i'm really hoping that with the
skills and
techniques and knowledge i learned from
this program i'll be able to apply it
into this research
i'm also hoping that i'll be able to use
this research to learn how to develop
this project
and also use this experience to make
connection and learn more about
postpartum depression
and how to properly research um topics
that cross between psychology and peer
science
and also could i ask you did you make an
account today
yes i did okay perfect so if you can
post the link the url link to your
account
so we can report that thank you now did
i hear correctly you were interested
in melanoma cancer but also uh
depression
oh i said i'm currently working on on
synthesizing one three diagonals
for treats for treating melanoma skin
cancer
and that's the research what i'm doing
now but in the future i'm trying to
build
this other research idea that i'm very
interested in
but i haven't really been able to find
material and
support for that so that's another
reason why i
decided to join this course and the
program
okay perfect so one thing i wanted to
mention to everybody who is joining
now every week we ask that
you submit a progress form
so we have this research fellowship
weekly progress report this is an
important part of what
you will be sharing with us
in terms of your progress i'm just going
to share the link
in the chat and we will follow up with
an
email so that you can take a look this
form
allows us to understand where you are in
your progress and helps you structure
your
progress and ask for meetings one-on-one
that solonica mentioned already
yes so thank you so much for sharing
that link too
and in here you will see different
stages
those stages are uh kind of where we can
help you
by identifying the type of help that we
can direct you to
either a free resource or something that
we've designed specifically for that
or how to schedule a meeting like i
mentioned with a mentor
okay thank you
thank you now i would want shilpa to
please introduce herself
hi uh everyone hello everyone uh i'm
shilpa total
um so i was born and brought up in india
um
i did my master's uh in the field of
biochemistry from kaplan
india um presently i'm pursuing my phd
in
environmental toxicology department at
southern minnesota
my dissertation work mainly um focuses
to explore the effect of uh pulmonary
and
hepatic toxicants like uh pentacle or
phenol and heat shock proteins and
autophagy
uh processing humans um so uh
in terms of molecular mechanism i'm
targeting mainly on protein homeostasis
mechanism
and on epigenetics too um so
um i want to include my uh so rna
sequencing in my designation work um
so that's why i um joined this class to
learn about the
data analysis and sequencing thank you
okay sorry we could not actually see
your video maybe it's dark
or maybe your camera is not working but
either way it's fine
so again did were you able to uh
complete your registration today yeah i
did
okay perfect all right great thank you
thank you so much everyone for joining
the meeting today
and we would be meeting soon i'll share
the links for those who want to join the
program
and if you have any sorts of queries you
can mail me
at marketing at the refine dot bio i'll
just type it in again for you
and i'm looking forward to hearing from
you
thank you so much for joining
you